[Music]
Hello everyone thank you to everyone present at
this demonstration workshop on the
Renault
of this workshop it doesn't matter to
present the main work that has
already started on his face and
on my Samsung
so from Renaud it's not because face
for the purpose of qualified welding on
the vehicles in the
context each time
to know if the
presently to know if there is
something the photos are on board
shows the quality doors
the look important is that you
have a  about 10
seconds
objective
operator
[Music]
current news at Renault so this
is where the audio photos from
Google automatically are located
and also there are lyrics
property first
content
[Music]
the position of the welds on the iPhone photos
the landscape environment of the program
and when I said a while ago my
big train of time need the condom
to classify
[Music
] from the
images
[Music]
training craft
today h  ui
[Music]
[ __ ] training so we did
how
[Music]
the training transformation chain
for example
transfer
between moment
today we have less than 2 seconds on
the calculations
then that's what I  wait
you see
[Music]
technique
to qualify the images
in the program
then the aunt you really are
[Music]
the volleyball application
this will be the result
there are a lot of people who are
involved
how to announce the models of
Google models
why
why  today in the process of
choosing
how do we manage to calibrate
a model we will be able to say this model is good
then from
[Music]
for the expectations
how much time is left
how to
manage others  device topics
[Music]
the question of representativeness
problem detection of
the question precisely to talk to me
we have 4 m
and therefore
the models
technology
[Music]
watch
for completely
habit  ations that have appeared is that
already
quantify them
for now the results
[Music]
pirate on a Renault
and other models on the game
results scheduled for the end of the game
I've been waiting for this is to have a  can
move on to the second theme
thank you hello
the lighter that takes the entry model
after a certain type of
[Music]
to do that we're going to be 2 years old close
to disturbances will call me at
the acquisition system
we're going we're going to talk  on the 2
door dead pixel we are going to talk about the
difference on the images
the goal in fact is going to be to specify
the noise range when we are in the
images so basically the
range is capable of giving results
a series  examples of what it can
give to generate on the images
so
different parameters
we're going to have
either the room is
completely
it's to shine a little bit the type
of
column is dead
[Music]
it's
the kind of disturbance that  are
applied to the
mo  dele
the results
of
so well it depends on the models
of the models today
the what is important on the caliph
[Music]
it is this kind of things on which
we try to work on
purpose
so use the Chartres library
[Music]
s visa  at the end of the match actually
to see her this
head
calls Rapiteau to
launch the tutorial from L'Express
it's rather the candidates on the
immigration conditions
impact of
the lighting on the model
of going out
puts three graphs in fact it's  3
different types of welding so the
pool with
5 different models so it's a
color and
lighting variation
so
in fact to see that it robust
which which model are the most sensitive
[Music]
and
for which type of welding because  that
suddenly in fact
turn off the use case
in
fact we have
[Music]
for an
analysis welding we see that it is the
same
whatever the model in target
it is
the types of models
C25 it is the model  of 5 apps
green welding
and belly dancing
[Music]
and all these images
in fact there is a random selection of
the images
what is the amplitude of rotation in
the city center
exactly
the a priori confidence therefore
in the gifts
gives  the list in depth and to
fetch information on the
dragons
on the results obtained
[Music]
Excel side by side
something
the images of Mali
I mean we will soon see you
on the kitchen
search not
list options  relative
to fruits
[Music]
there are plenty of things in the chain
model et
cetera
the last advancement of 7
is Orleans
[Music]
no
proportion confusion quality
[Music]
use
in fact you choose
[Music]
that the model input data is going to
be in line with two areas
of operation
[Music]
and the page the range operation of the model
it's really detect and
to
try and model instead of doing to
work  on French people
it has the probability that it crashes is
high
I will have entered
the operator
in this case anyway
it's really it's really
on the analyzes
information of the day
and so we are really on a
block parallel to the expectation of the model
which qualifies a
confidence score at the output on the on the
operator model
there is a problem
images
[Music]
integrate the objective part
thank you for your question
we will go to
8 p.m.
it consists in fact of
taking  1 bottles of coke
and
how she reacted to her
side how we
make the day
naturally on images like that we're
going to focus on
herself
[Music]
if we can have
so to work on that we had
the chance to have several libraries
so the first
explains
the current work
[Music]
the limitations of the ASSR 2
gives good results
plane to go you have the
knowledge ask
time for  r the results of the water swims
from the German
because
since
several models and
I believe
that focusing on the welding
same thing is the recipe that we
see regularly in this presentation
yet we realize that it is a  little
more and therefore the same same and at the drive-thru or
another
you have pizza the whole team
right next door
a second life
it's the
starting signal to
work also on the road
they worked on the pirates
they worked  on basically
on 4 4 mode is still blurry so me
tomorrow and they used so it's an
alarm
so as agreed earlier.  In
addition there are problems with the
terrace and the calculation time for that
also to settle it because
they will also have computing power
at 8 p.m.
it's sure
hard with on the one hand
what the inference provides so they have
worked on which elements of the
give african pixel
of increase the
dance of the result
result
on the
reference
the operator passes on the 7 and
the result
and the third the library
to work it is good
then there this this library we have
more than  to them it is not currently
usable on the two
simply because to
calibrate that is to say in the position
where the weld bead always in the same
place always well
therefore without deformation
the center of science without rotation
of the images  with the welding bead
superimposed in the same place
library provide results
to test it on some some images
relationship with the lens team
working and they are
working on the  possibility
of going a little further to work
on the on the images
I'm going to talk to myself about the work
[Music]
I
want to arrive at models who are
but the approach
how long we will be able to say
that it is  much more robust
then do the simple loop
of network training and
and examples
it would have to come is that the hob
example of situation
left images
[Music]
but so the it to be a member
[Music  ]
the TV network by
training from there so we will
try to make a comparison between
the networks of Rennes
[Music]
and order disturbance of the order of
10 - 3 years that we lower the
every  original images
[Music]
density of gold
compare
[Music]
but we always come to the same conclusion
that
show me they go
[Music]
the louder
I presented you
the work than to do
the results
the  approach that resembles  not bad
so at the end we
want regions
[Music]
a song of many
on the other hand
[Music]
and in order therefore messages as soon as
they are
[Music]
when takes place
have a report  on the quality of
how we will understand
in relation to
[Music]
facilitate the work we will
understand sorry to hear
from you to find out
suddenly to investigate
then
to watch
[Music]
we will do the  same thing
so we can use it to watch
[Music]
watch the results of the phone call
on the different
I have to buy the color on the
crow and the different models
we can
add suddenly
to have a
weird
evaluation turn on the TV
we  going to see
watching the couple so from
tomorrow
evaluate on the on the
colors
find the color on the news I
have to prepare for the next shot
indeed
[Music]
we will be able to
sorry
is 410
it's normal  l
so there
done by hand operations
the observation list
create a task on allocations
a small database
we're going to come back to sites to
look at
so
we're going to put
[Music]
Google
Apps
I want to cook
you're orange
at  from
add frying
ok we will simply look at
the distribution of the letters
[Music]
you can repeat that suddenly add
as we did at the bottom right
work on a planet
put on a song
thank you all for the presence thank you
[Applause]